the note for slot partner khosla
ventures well I think I'm in the
business of funding those great
technological ideas that can cause
breakthroughs in technology in all areas
but we have a strong focus on energy and
energy revolution not enough innovation
has happened in the energy business the
traditional oil companies don't spend
any money on real oddity in new areas
they spend most of their time and money
on getting more oil out of the ground
and researching that and so I think that
the lack of real talent and creativity
and innovation in energy research and
that's what we are trying to find both
of the early stage and then taking them
to commercialization well I started
looking at the environmental movement in
the 90s I've always considered myself a
fairly concerned person about those
issues but what I found in the 90s was
most organizations for working on small
pieces of the solution not really things
that could change the fundamentals what
does changing the fundaments mean we
have to wean ourselves off oil and we
have to wean ourselves off call if we do
those two we are eighty percent of the
way where we need to be and so I then
started to address those two big issues
I really started to learn about it a
long time ago started dabbling in energy
investing in 2001 or so and then over
time have picked up steam